[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mon petit doigt
vient de me dire un secret le nom ne
mesurant pas trop il m'a dit qu'il
fallait que tu descendent vite chez
nicolas et pimprenelle plein sûr que je
te sont mon le chef europe pour propos
peu pas beaucoup
mon petit doigt m'a dit que nicolas et
pimprenelle vont faire une belle
surprise à nounours mais bon soir le
petit c'est pour toi le show leaf lors
du voilà c'est une belle image pour toi
on veut je suis battu
mon dieu c'était pas ma femme s'est pas
tu as fait c'est parce que tu aimes
c'est pour te faire plaisir ce qu'ils
peuvent être gentil quand il le bol
assieds toi et écoute
c'est ainsi pour faire plaisir au co
comment ça commence pas pr neil la sical
la cigale et la fourmi la cigale et la
fourmi la cigale ayant chanté tout l'été
c'est trouva fort dépourvue quand la
bise fut venue
pas un seul petit morceau de mousse ou
de vernis sur la poubelle à la criée
famille sheila four mais sa voisine la
priant de lui prêter quelques grappes
pour subsister jusqu'à jusque jusqu'à la
saison nouvelle
je vous pourrez lui dit 'le avant nous
foi d'animal intérêt et principal à moi
la fourmi n'est pas prêteuse
c'est là son moindre défaut chez vous au
temps chaud dit elle c'est un plus au
temps chaud ne vous déplaise je chantais
à tout venant
vous chantiez je suis forte et bien
dansez maintenant
ah la la voilà je danse 9,8 me mettre au
boulot fin bravo vous en savez de jolies
choses c'est maman qui me l'a appris
c'est une fable et on l'a prise pour toi
la fable jeu la raconterai à mes neveux
merci mes chers petits dagnino ce jeu
vous à qu'on n'en on va se coucher tout
seuls comme des grands
bonne nuit mon école a fait pour être un
prenait
[Musique]
alors tu es content de nous re fortron
husson trolio
si nous leur faisions une grande
surprise
des coûteux c'est une très bonne idée
ils vont être tellement content out
nounours ni les enfants fait boureux
oh
[Musique]
en
o o